i so many friends have told me how good
top gun is oh yeah i got to talk about
so many people yeah todd feldman who
tell me it was good though don't [ __ ] me
up dude so top five getting away i'm not
so todd feldman who represents director
he's like dude i'm telling you the top
gun for years he's like your boy miles
tillerson who's one of my first friends
of mine in la
all there's so many reasons i should see
it i've never been a big top gun guy
when i was a kid i was like you know
whatever i like right the video game top
gun i enjoyed that i'm not a fighter
yeah yeah
yeah i can't find the play i'm too big
it was never my thing but it's
so many reviews i've seen i'm like well
[ __ ] sakes dude and then jay who does
not talk like this
text me
because i you know we text non-stop and
i go dude what have you been doing to us
i mean uh his wife he went to the movies
what did you see it was top guy how was
it
in jay's words and you know he didn't
talk unless he was phenomenal oh geez
i went i went relaxed big that went
relaxed i mean i went phenomenal what do
you gotta go what are you our dad that's
what my dad says after he's a good meal
phenomenal friend so i go all right we
gotta see it so it was a random uh what
did i go see i think yeah saturday
saturday night did a date night with
wife we we go there
she you know she's born and raised in
mexico she doesn't know [ __ ] about tom
cruise top gun nothing she goes i see
the first one i go i don't think you
have to they do a good job you don't
have to
she cried four times for the movie
dude it got done i've never seen a movie
this happened a movie it got done the
entire theater stood up and clapped what
my girl tears dude mexican [ __ ] crew
mexican [ __ ] tears tears tears tears
i gotta watch this movie that's taking
myself i watched the whole movie like
this
it's so intense and so entertaining the
whole movie like this
dude i'm taking my son and my daughter
it's so good i'm doing that i'm gonna
hit you right in the fields and you
don't need to see the first one they do
such a great job of telling the story of
the past yeah so you don't you just need
to know the major i hear miles teller
looks so much like anthony oh
oh he's good he's good oh he's good
right
i'm telling and it's so dope cause you
know tom cruise and mr impossible in the
[ __ ] he you know how long pretend he's
not 50 you know doing all these stunts
and [ __ ] like this and this one he
actually takes a back seat and
acknowledges that he's older and he
plays like the mentor like he
acknowledges his age and he's getting
older and his time has passed time for
him first time that's at first it's so
good dude when it starts isn't a spoiler
when it starts
tom cruise street clothes hey everybody
tom cruise here
we specifically made sure this movie
didn't come out it's been done for years
four years i think he was
specifically made sure this movie was to
be seen in the theater
the g-forces are real the jets are real
just for you guys gotta go to the
theater for this oh i have to go theater
oh i'm going and i'm a big no theater
guy dude
oh i'm i'm going i'm 100.
now just to give you a little cheesy
little heads up yeah
the first the first 10 minute little
cheesy and i was like i made a mistake
coming everyone's lame as [ __ ] well a
little bit because
that that america right yeah which i'm
on board with yep dude i wore them uh
[ __ ] american bandana
yeah the thing is is they keep referring
to each other as their pilot names so
they're going hey hangman what's up new
top dog oh what's up sonic and it's like
well let's use each other's real names
and stop talking like that yeah and in
my head i'm like oh this movie's super
corny yeah
it gets past that i would tell you the
story i was writing a script about a
soldier that's still working on